prozac turns guppies into zombies
is the headline so this from science
news
and uh zach i'm sorry i need
i need this back just for a minute to
pull up the original research
and here we go psychoactive pollution
suppresses individual differences in
fish behavior
says crew pulverino at all um and
okay i'm sorry z i need thank you um
what do i want to read here okay the
first paragraph the introduction in the
last two decades the variety and
concentration of pharmaceuticals in the
environment has grown substantially
most pharmaceuticals including
psychoactive drugs such as
antipsychotics
and anxiolytics such as anti-anxiety
meds
and antidepressants are only partially
absorbed after ingestion
and once excreted are not fully removed
by wastewater treatment
such pollutants make their way into the
environment via wastewater remaining
biologically active in aquatic
ecosystems
as a result pollution by psychoactive
drugs is now ubiquitous in aquatic
ecosystems around the world
entering food webs and accumulating in
living organisms
and um environmental contamination by
pharmaceuticals is global substantially
altering crucial behaviors in animals
and impacting on their reproduction and
survival
a key question is whether the
consequences of these pollutants extend
beyond mean
behavioral changes restraining
differences in behavior between
individuals i don't think i need to read
all of this
to understand the proximate mechanism of
underlying these changes we tested the
relative contribution of variation
within and between individuals to the
overall decline in individual variation
we found strong evidence that fluoxetine
which is the name of prozac
erodes variation in activity between but
not within individuals
revealing the hidden consequences of a
ubiquitous contaminant on phenotypic
variation in fish
which is likely to impair adaptive
potential to environmental change
in english that is um
in english what that means is that
basically
fish are um much
less likely to show
wide variation from the mean of what
their personalities at the population
level are
if they've been exposed to even low
levels of prozac in the water
and apparently most water supplies in
most of the world are at this point a
wash in low levels of prozac which
is something that i actually did not
know um the high levels of prozac in the
water
are going to be the case at basically
near your sewer
outlets um but these low levels
um actually render these they looked at
guppies you know they collected these
guppies from one of the few places i
think it was australia where there's
really no prozac pollution in the water
and they put them in a lab for i think
it was six years
and exposed them to lab conditions in
which there was no fluoxetine low levels
of fluoxetine or high levels of
fluoxetine
and at both high and low they found that
these fish were just
much more likely to be average than
um you know behave like average fish
than
they did when they were not exposed to
prozac at all
and you know it i i remember when prozac
was becoming a thing
right and this was you know this was
sort of the description it'd be like
well you expect your moods to be like
this
and some people's moods are way high and
way low we need to flatten it out and
it's just this
flattening you know this is this is the
really nasty flattening the curve
unlike what we're trying to do with
covid right and
um you know maybe you don't want to
flatten people's moods so much that they
cannot
actually experience and respond to the
insults and joys that life throws at
them and also
maybe the fact that this appears to
affect fish in the same way
suggests that we ought not be doing this
to you know
all of the vertebrates on the planet
including humans
yeah i mean obviously the
all moods good and bad are adaptations
you could be dysregulated in some way
that you're prone to certain moods and
away from others but the chances that
that is a widespread problem rather than
you live in a
nonsense environment that's creating
anxiety because it's almost impossible
to navigate well
and therefore we're going to medicate
you out of recognizing that you're
actually imperiled every day by
you know a a cruddy world right that's
that's a non-solution and
you know okay so we're externalizing the
same garbage onto fish
that will of course mean all kinds of
things one
if you're taking these you know the
equivalent of fish moods
and flattening them those fish will not
do
as well as they would which means they
will end up preyed upon more frequently
failing to be properly motivated to
forage and
probably starve more frequently than
they would otherwise speed up the
extinction crisis right you're going to
you're going to contribute in some way
to
to the extinction crisis it is also the
case that you're now
creating a weird puzzle for creatures
more generally
where some creatures are going to be
intensely in the outflow of this stuff
and they will certainly evolve to being
less sensitive to it
right the less sensitive they are which
means that they will then experience
fish anxiety at the point that they
you know swim somewhere that it's less
concentrated so how does that work
an epidemic of angry guppies right
um which they could be very i don't know
nibbly or something but
um but yeah the you know so
the lesson is always the same which is
in nature knows what it's doing
and if you disrupt it you are very
unlikely to make things better and very
likely to make things worse and
you know it should not be any shock to
us at all but it should give us pause i
mean for one thing
we're also downstream from all this
stuff even those of us who don't take
these things
are undoubtedly getting a certain amount
of it
that we shouldn't be and uh you know
there's no way
to opt out yeah there's no way to opt
out and this observation that um
this observation that it doesn't get
treated by wastewater treatment
like how is it that
a drug as widely used as prozac was
allowed to go to market when there was
no way to disable it
well i mean this is this is the story
everywhere is that you know
it's hard to put your finger on exactly
what the problem is going to be until
the entities that created this stuff are
so powerful that you can't tell them no
but this is one of our um this is one of
the
nights of our hanukkah tradition right
so so long time viewers and listeners
will know
we've talked about before and it's in
fact the epilogue of our book
um the eight for the eight nights of
hanukkah we
we talk about one thing that we think
modern humans should be living by
and the one that i'm referring to here
i'm not going to have the language quite
right
but basically anything new that you put
into the world
you need to be able to undo before you
put it into the world
all human activity should be both
sustainable and reversible and
reversible is there because of this
uh this process whereby anything that's
economically profitable
becomes irreversible and that you know
so many you know
everybody seems to know that social
media is driving us insane
right and yet it's not even conceivable
that we could do anything like
cut it out right um you know that's not
on the table of solutions we're gonna
have to
find enough band-aids to deal with the
insanity of the
entire human population rather than
realize we made a mistake and
undo it so yeah yeah so
you know in in the general scheme of
things how high
does a narrowing of the spectrum of
personality types and guppies
rank as things you're concerned about i
expect um
no one at the end of today will be able
to uh say yeah that's
that's in my top 10. but as a horseman
as an indicator of what it is that we're
doing
you know in terms of effects that
apparently no one was thinking of
not only are we flattening whole swaths
of the human population with regard to
diversity personality types
this thing that we're letting them take
all of us are then getting some of it
and all the vertebrates who are in water
or who drink water
are getting some of it and we're all
affected because these are ancient
ancient
ancient receptors and it's affecting
everyone
and it's it is going to this is going to
be one
tiny little parameter that is going to
affect things like the extinction crisis
because you get a you know you
effectively have a less diverse
behavioral repertoire in any population
and it's going to be able to deal with
change less well of course it will well
and
you know the irony of ironies which i'm
sure you're going to end up speaking
about at some point at length on the
podcast is that the entire
hypothesis on which this pharmaceutical
solution was predicated it was wrong to
begin with and wasn't plausible to begin
with
right the idea that you know some large
fraction of the population is suffering
from chemical imbalances that need us to
come in there and
you know retune their reabsorption rate
of these things
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make
any sense anymore then
you know there's suddenly a genetic
crisis that is causing
children's jaws to be malformed relative
to their teeth or we're a
terrible species that happens to rule
the world oh my goodness so much
mutation that is just crept in and we
just
need medicine to save us from each and
every feature of our beings that is
coming apart genetically it's nonsense
yeah um so yeah now these drugs so we we
will at some point spend a long time
on this but yeah you you have it in a
nutshell
um treating chemical imbalance very very
very rarely creating chemical imbalance
pretty much always that's what they're
doing yep
that's what these these neuroleptics and
antipsychotics and anti-anxiety and
anti-depression meds
are doing creating chemical imbalance
not resolving it
yes and in fish great
terrific
[Music]
you